une rue paisible de saint-benoît sans
grand caractère mais au nom chargé
d'histoire dans la rue ce qu billion il
y à une école est ce un moyen de ne pas
oublier l'oeuvre du frère qui était
scooby doo a encore pâle scooby doo
c'est un personnage de bande dessinée
marais j'ai posé la question si on est
dans la liste et millions ski millions
c'est bellion scubilion c'est parce que
ces militaires religieux c'est un pays
en voie de la vespière frère qui
s'occupait des esclaves et tuent les
pauvres et toutes ces villes à libérer
les esclaves et leur redonner confiance
et l île brown
dernièrement il était enterré à sainte
marie jean bernard rousseau est né en
bourgogne en 1797 en pleine révolution
d'abord instituteur ce n'est qu'à l'âge
de 25 ans qu'il entre dans l'ordre des
frères des écoles chrétiennes avec
l'habit religieux
il reçoit le nom de frère scubilion
ayant prononcé ses voeux perpétuels il
va pouvoir vivre son rêve de terres
lointaines en 1833 il est désigné pour
partir à l'île bourbon
à son arrivée il constate une situation
des tensions liées à l' esclavage
il reste trois ans en poste à saint
benoît puis par à saint paul avant de
s'installer à saint leu là il entreprend
l'évangélisation et la scolarisation des
noirs une initiative soutenue par jean
baptiste de villèle et madame desbassyns
car elle contribue à l'insertion sociale
mais l'oeuvre de frère scubilion ne
s'arrête pas à saint leu il fait le tour
de l'île de la possession à salazie en
passant par sainte marie partout il mène
son action d'apostolat auprès des noirs
il crée des écoles du soir et dispense
des cours de catéchisme à sainte marie
de guérison inexpliquée attire même
l'attention du public
il meurt le 13 avril 1867 il est d'abord
enterré à sainte marie puis en 1947 sa
dépouille sera déposé dans un mausolée
enfin en 1989 le pape jean paul ii en
voyage dans l'île le béatifie lors d'une
cérémonie sur l'esplanade de la trinité
de saint denis